what's going on everybody and welcome to
the third Monte Carlo simulation within
Python tutorial video the last video we
made our simple better we saw a few
sample outcomes but now let's go ahead
and see a larger amount of these
outcomes
so the first thing we want to do is
first let's silence a lot of these
pronounced work we're content with with
with our results here so we don't need
to really have them there they were only
there for debugging the next thing we
want to do is instead of printing funds
every step of the way we'll just shift
this over and we're only going to print
funds at the very end now lastly we want
to we'll just create a quick counter
function and do the following we'll just
have x equals zero Wow
X is less than 100 we'll run this and
then X plus equals one and that's that
so let's go ahead and run it and so this
is a sample outcome from a hundred
different betters you know well how much
money did they make basically by the end
of a hundred wagers with 49 percent odds
of winning so we've got a loss of win a
loss a break-even profit loss profit
profit profit profit some people did
pretty good as you can see some people
did really good um some people didn't do
so hot
this guy's seventy eight hundred I don't
know he might be the biggest loser in
this crowd looks like you know seventy
two hundred is our biggest loser anyway
the yeah the point to bring home those
you can see that there is quite the
spread here given the exact same a
strategy that's used that said this
person would probably be called you know
a successful gambler or in this sense of
trading this would be our successful
trader and his strategy would somehow be
so much better than this other person
strategy who you know ended with seventy
two hundred dollars but they use the
exact same identical strategy anyway
moving on the next thing that we could
do is say our simple better what we
could do is at the end of the simple
better
um we could come down here after current
wager we can come down here and outside
of our while loop let's just say if
value is less than zero we'll just say
value equals broke okay so now instead a
wager count right now we have it set at
a hundred let's set it at ten thousand
so these these betters will do ten
thousand wagers but we'll still only
have a hundred of them a hundred betters
rather but ten thousand wagers we can
see that quite a few of these guys
actually went broke looking through it
looks like only one person actually
profited the rest of the people either
went broke or they lost money so this
guy made some money so anyways so that's
that I just wanted to show you guys on a
grander scale with our simple better
also it's a little it's it's hard to see
the trajectory of these guys because
right now we're only showing the final
outcome for these poor poor fellows
which for the most part was broke but
obviously there's more to the story than
just the end result right we want to
know along the way how did it go so
again with if you have trading in mind
one of the key factors for risk
assessment is how much drawdown did your
account experience so for all the gains
that you made how much did you lose in
the meantime so soon we'll see as we're
going to add a better as people try to
employ more and more strategies a lot of
times you're going to see drawdown
increase and so that kind of gives you a
red flag because at any given time you
could experience that drawdown and for
some traders that drawdown is actually
the threat of blowing up their account
which means just going to zero or even
losing money for some of these guys so
anyways that's what we're gonna do in
the next video we're going to actually
display this visually in matplotlib so
real quick at the beginning of the video
I'll show you guys how to download
matplotlib and all
that but you will need matplotlib so
stay tuned for the next video as always
thanks for watching thanks for all the
support the subscriptions and until next
time